[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we still get music that's a new hot
track for riffing with Griffin made by
mg M J X
Mack Zilla on Instagram I'm gonna have
all this information so people are still
sending theme song so you can still send
a hot track like that we got it Oh who
are you step in opening up boxes on the
show I just wish I can rap you know no
man I'm just not a rapper you know what
I mean listen this is just another quick
clip episode I just wanted to thank
everybody for listening and watching
with from what Griffin and right here I
have a bunch of stuff right here that I
got on my Peele box that I want to open
up right now someone to say thank you to
everybody so once again that was us I'm
still getting new music so I want to say
thank you to that guy again mr. mjx
right make sure I'm saying his name
right did you know we don't want to get
that wrong let's see yeah MJ X maxilla
he calls himself
so and he's still working on that track
for me so and maybe I'll write down some
real rhymes and let that go but yeah I
want to thank all the guests and I want
to thank you for subscribing and liking
and sharing and all that stuff so anyway
I just want to get to this right now
there's going to be a quick video maybe
5-10 minutes at the tops at tops you
know so right away
all right first thing up okay so I got
this little card from David Dixon sent
to riff and what Griffin all right let's
see what David has to say okay oh wow
this [ __ ] wrote a whole Eric
Sawyer post on Twitter about sending you
fan art I'm a musician but can't draw or
paint for [ __ ] I did want to tell you
that some heartfelt [ __ ] though
I got let's see I got familiar with you
from workaholics and I always thought
you you were funny as hell I've enjoyed
your standup and specials - you work on
them dying up here was especially
impressive I had never seen you in you
know serious roles I thought you killed
it and congrats on your success and hard
work keep you know keep doing something
I can't really read his handwriting but
best David Dixon but Dave thank you very
much man I appreciate that these are the
kind of things that mean something you
know what I mean we're gonna put that
right up here that's going up there from
now on or someplace I don't know we'll
figure it out all right next up we got
from dawn or Dan Garcia
all right so oh this is hilarious
so guys Dan sent me his resume okay so I
know people want to help I know you guys
you know you wanna you know you see what
I'm doing
he's got a producer video editor youth
soccer referee cuz that's what I need
around here is a youth suck use I was
looking for but I appreciate the effort
of sending a resume I'm just not at the
point right now where I'm looking to
hire somebody and maybe I'm looking for
an intern or somebody to help me out for
a little while as I grow because you
know I don't I just aren't them the cash
ain't flowing to the point where I could
have a paid staff yet you know what I
mean but I'm working on that all right
but I'm gonna thank him Dan Garcia
thanks for sending that all right
so we got here it says fragile ooh ooh
okay here we go
all right okay okay oh my god just got a
box of that could be a black mamba in
here for all I know there's gonna be
some Kill Bill situation okay
well let's see there's a lot of oh my
god it's okay
Wow
I don't know what what is like the whole
box is full of this like there's a trash
can right here yeah so you sent a lot of
uh I just got a box full of shredded
paper everybody that's exciting
let's see what's in here Wow oh yeah
this is the candle candle guy he sent
some candles I think he sent some too -
Theo - all right yeah he makes special
candles okay
rogue farms grow the revolution all
right
orgasmic ale gasps McHale y'all don't
know about that Oh gasps McHale oh
there's more in here - look at that
okay let's see what we got here
[Music]
Belgium style blonde mmm Belgium style
blonde
I like it a lot I think wait I think
that's that's everything all right
there's no card just a lot of this stuff
packs goddamn all right well thank you
dude
I appreciate that from Jay Piemonte
hangover candle company hangover candle
company sent me some some dope-ass
candles you know we're gonna light those
[ __ ] and see how they smell
all right next up last up last but not
least this one's from Michael pass car
and this one also says fragile on it so
that's of course this is back to the
missus Ike this was Christmas morning
and I was 5 years old I'd be so mad okay
here we go or just a card okay this is
black ops all right okay Eric hello I'm
a man of my word it's been a fun project
thinking up and building something
unique and special for you and your
podcast I hope you like it and enjoy for
a long time thanks for the laughs keep
up the fun and your goal to be number
one on on blackout yeah that is my goal
if you watch Griffin govern we need to
sing it Mike Griffin Jamie yeah
girlfriend gaming the packaging includes
the patches I designed for this
specialist and original piece of my own
art painted on wood
the lightbox is simple to operate with
the remote enjoy
Michael pass car Wow so he sent me some
light let's see what this is oh pretty
dope
look at that okay he drew this himself
oh this is like a thing that they made
that's this is that's pretty damn
wonderful right there maybe I'll like
take a picture of that and put that up
you know what I mean so she would go see
that and here so this is like some kind
of black ops thing you know all right
let's see what's in the box though they
said even like the main thing I got to
keep this car at this park because he
wrote on that it's not a pretty dope
okay here we go okay okay oh this is
some kind of this is some kind of
electronics he make Wow
I don't know what I don't know what the
[ __ ] this is well let's see we have two
okay we have to open this okay oh dude
okay let's put this [ __ ] box down
check that out
it says riffin with griffin like a
podcast thing you know and I think it
lights up or something this is like I
don't know yeah there you go
[ __ ] look at dad that's dope y'all
that's dope is it rubber gripper and it
has like a remote control so you can
like the [ __ ] lights up wait let's see
if it works I don't know if it works
oh look at that oh look at different
colors you could turn it red you could
turn it yellow oh wow I don't even know
what to say
that is spectacular and we're gonna find
our place
oh no while for this I think it's time
for my fake fish to come down huh so we
gonna have to anyways we gonna have to
fix wait let's put that let's put that
right here yeah you know turn it on and
let's change colors make it blue oh look
at that
that is dope man Wow
so anyways you guys are this is funky
fresh
I really appreciate I'm speechless right
now cuz people sent me this stuff so we
got that fan art from Willy you guys
have seen that one has been here the
whole time but now we got some candles I
got some great some great words from
people and I'm just like I'm really
touched it you guys are watching the
show like this and I I truly appreciate
you know everything that you guys are
doing you know the likes to do all that
stuff you know what I mean
just keep that going in want to thank
mjx for the snow fast beat I just want
to thank everybody for everything they
sent and I want you guys to keep
subscribing keep sharing I'm gonna keep
making the content and having fun doing
it they should check out groups engaging
if you want to send me something make
sure you send it to riffle with Griffith
P o box two three four three nine nine
Los Angeles California
9z rosie row three four
[Music]
[ __ ] like up just like this
we got the candles and the music
everybody knows I'm gonna use it
[Music]